[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
ten of Africa's greatest chess players
compete in Abidjan as Vivendi presents
the 2018 cote d'ivoire
rapid and glitz Invitational hello chess
fans and welcome back to st. Louis for
something a little bit different my name
is Ben Simon and I'm joined this time by
Grandmaster Robert Len gaskey hey Ben
hello everybody and his live-streaming
debut this is gonna be a lot of fun it
is I'm pretty nervous too but I hope
it's gonna be a lot of fun yeah it'll be
a great time because we are presenting a
tournament remotely today this is a
tournament in Abidjan in the Ivory Coast
we have ten of the best players from all
of Africa and they have converged to
show their skills in quick chess it's a
mixed format tournament styled after the
grand chester and it's all presented by
Vivendi in collaboration with Kasparov
chess foundation Africa and KCF
francophone as well as the st. Louis
chess club so this is gonna be a lot of
fun I can't wait now we are presenting
90 minutes of coverage each day two
rounds today have already been played as
far as Rapids go but we'll get to that
whenever we look at the format a little
bit later on but let's take a look at
the names and see who will be playing in
this tournament Robert we have ten
nations represented there's no doubling
up here and there you can see on the
left based on the feed a ranking there
were there Africa ranked on the entire
continent this is a very strong field
what stands out to you well first of all
like you said seeing such diversity in
terms of representation in a tournament
makes it tournament true to its you know
international nature you know sometimes
you hear about like the World Series but
it's usually like all US teams here
we're seeing ten players from ten
different countries and of course what
stands out the most is the number one
seed of Cena men heavy hitter absolutely
I mean and we look at the rating on the
right side you'll notice that we are
using the universal rating system for
this event
that was the system made famous by the
grand chest tour and it is it is the
super group of chest ratings let me say
this rating is a measurement of
performance across all time controls so
how appropriate we use it for this rapid
and blitz event and by any metric you
will see feed a universal rating
anything else that
Bassem mean is about 200 points higher
than his number 2 in any metric so
that's amazing
yeah it's also worth pointing out that
Vasan Amin is the first player in
African history to cross that 2,700 feet
a rating barrier now we see that that
Universal rating system he's also pretty
close but maybe you can explain a little
bit some of the differences between
universal rating system and fidei
systems so right so the universal rating
system like I said is a measurement
along all time controls so it's saying
that all classical all rapid in all
blitz games have value but that value is
different and it's on a scale okay
there's no cutoff at 30 minutes there's
no cutoff at 1 hour it's all on a
sliding scale so instead of having three
different ratings there's many different
time controls you just have one rating
that weighs it all exactly it's not an
average of other ratings it's not it's
not a an e low rating that resembles it
but it is different entirely different
in its calculation but we'll talk about
that more later on
now this tournament has mixed time
controls as I said here's the format
we'll be going at at five days strong
for the first three days will have rapid
chess for the last two days we'll have
blitz chess we're in day one right now
the time control is game in 25 with a
ten-second delay when it's all said and
done you will see one round-robin of
rapid being played nine games for 10
players and I grounds for 10 players
each game is weighted 2 points and this
will play out through the 27th today
tomorrow and the day after now you were
asking earlier about why is the game
worth 2 points yeah I'm I get confused
easily so I ask
a lot of questions like with the rating
system you know when I see something new
I really want to make sure I get what
it's about so I see that each game is
worth 2 points as opposed to I guess one
so if you win a game you get two points
right and if you draw you get one
exactly and if you lose do you get half
zero point oh man that's pretty rough
you get nothing for losing all right
okay so but that is because we have a
blitz portion and we we need to wait it
because I think most pelisses chess
players would agree that rapid games are
are worth more than blitz just because
you have more time to think they are
more skillfully played let's take a look
at the Blitz it's game in five minutes
with a three-second delay that and it's
a double round-robin event to be played
over two days that means that on
Saturday you will see one full round
robin of blitz man that's exciting and
on Sunday you're gonna see the same
thing each game is worth one point
the typical scoring one and then half
for a draw and a zero for a lost they're
gonna have nine games in one day so that
would be nine points for granted they'll
start every half-hour yeah it's gonna be
intense and you can see all of that at
chess 24 comm and join the conversation
on twitter with hashtag africa chess so
you know they don't actually use twitter
too much in africa I've told really yeah
it's about time we change that yeah
let's see we'll see if we can change the
Twitter world after this event is over
now we have already started play today
this is the third round we're about to
start at the top of the hour but the
other two rapid games at other two rapid
rounds is this day have already ceased
so if we have them I'd like to take a
look at the standings going into round
three of the rapids so far now to be
expected well look who we have at the
top but it's it's not a total blowout
you know it's not a 400 deal right
because at first you look at these
standings anything Oh three rounds three
points you think he won all his games
but we have to remember that with this
point system
he just won it
just won one game and I guess drew one
or it drew three but I think he yeah he
won one and drew one and that means he
lost one where drew three we don't we
don't have the breakdown yet look at me
should take a later on this after round
two so he won one game oh he drew that
yeah so we're getting ahead of ourselves
we are coming in at the middle of the
day yeah we're just getting a head up
okay so these are the standings so far
and it's very important to get off to a
good start hit the ground running so to
speak because when you get to the Blitz
rounds will kind of know where everybody
stands you know we receipt we have seen
rapid and blitz tournaments in the Grand
chest tour in the past where Wesley so
is just destroy in the field and then
you go into the Blitz and it's a
formality kind of so it's much harder to
regain ground in the Blitz portion
because of the halving of the points
yeah also Wesley it's a pretty good
blood supply yeah it's not like he's
gonna be too worried about going into
the Blitz portion right but yeah I mean
considering that the rapid gains are
weighted more heavily this is a great
opportunity to really create that little
buffer right going into the blitz
portion so we've set the stage so far
we've got ten hungry players looking to
make their name some of some of whom on
the the world stage for the first time
mm-hmm
and but they're not playing for free you
know you've got some good prizes no
money involved yeah oh yeah there's some
money involved Robert I know right so
keep talking let's take a look at what's
on the line the prizes for this event
it's a fifteen thousand dollar prize
fund which I have been told by the
organizer Graham Jorgenson who is the
head of KCF Africa that this is probably
the richest prize fund in any African
quick tournament ever so this is this is
a big deal the first five places will be
going home with an incremental prize
there you see of $1,000 each one and the
grand prize the champion of the African
Chesterman at the cote d'ivoire
rapid and blitz will be leaving
with $5,000 so good stuff to look
forward to rapidly not a bad chunk of
change now I see we are beginning the
games in about six minutes and we don't
have a live feed of the tournament hall
for you as of yet
but we'll be working on that as the time
goes on so while we're waiting for the
games has there been anything that's
stuck out in your mind from the games
that have happened so far today yeah
absolutely I'm impressed by the
craziness of the games I mean these were
fighting games and I mean it round two
I am looking at round - do you wanna
start with round one I mean no pretty
crazy hey I'm good I'm giving you the
floor here yeah let's let's take a look
at this game from slim Bell hoja and
vocalist Ella and Nami and you we were
talking about Boston amine as being the
player to watch but slim Belko dia he is
I believe the first Grandmaster in
African history right so another legend
in the field
so let's took it take a look at this
game started with E 4 C 5 92 96 93 so we
have a chameleon variation but this
started going off the rails pretty quick
I mean look at after G 3 we see H 5 and
this is what I was talking about this is
not the exception and the tournament's
from what i've seen so seen so far all
players are going all-out
so after h3e 5 Bishop g2 d6 d3
white sort of castled into this attack
on h5 which at first i thought was a
little bit optimistic because usually
when your opponent is attacking you on a
flank you want to castle the other way
right and generally i don't know what
your opinion is on castling but I
consider it a defensive move so if I
have more useful things I can do in the
meantime like finish my development for
example I'll consider it move like
Bishop e3 which I know I want to make so
after Bishop e3 if black goes Knight d4
I'm still gonna delay my castling and
I'll go Queen d2 and like Magnus Carlsen
likes to say I can always pull the
emergency brake and Castle queenside if
I think if I see things getting a little
bit too ugly on the Kings side and sure
enough in the game White Castle and
after 94 f4 black point for the King
side attack with h4 g4 and guess what
happened here Knight takes g4
sacrificing a piece to open up some
lines on the White King after pawn takes
Bishop takes and black gets to pick two
pawns for the night and I'm not so sure
if the attack is winning I don't think
its winning but in a rapid time control
this is probably not an easy position to
be handling with white definitely much
more comfortable as black white goes
king h2 hoping to use the black pawn
page 4 as a shelter for his King
he takes f4 rook takes Bishop h5 and
this is what I was saying there's no
clear path of attack for black but black
can just hold the position and count on
the problems that White's gonna have
with his King safety as a long-term
mission usually we don't think of an
attack as having you know long long-term
prospects but I think that's what we see
here
so after Bishop e3 g5 rook f1
Bishop f6 so now this bishops coming to
e5 and we see that these pawns on h4 and
g5 along with this fish up coming to e5
and the bishop on h5 and slicing through
the board and making life very
uncomfortable for this King on h2 would
you be worried if you are white I would
be very worried yes like I said I
generally like to delay cancelling as
long as I can because I for one do not
care for being attacked some players you
know they enjoy the complications
they'll gladly take the piece and you
know wiggle around for 10 or 20 moves
and then come out a piece ahead and win
the game Larry Evans was famous for for
this type of approach you know he would
just take everything you put in front of
him and then use his defensive resources
to outplay you and eventually keep the
material in win so after Bishop takes C
takes 95 Bishop b5
I think this position aside from having
an attack you have pretty reasonable
positional compensation as well because
you have the bishop whoa what happened
that went too fast yeah
so after Bishop b5 you have this
beautiful bishop on a central outpost
you have the bishop pair and you have
this possibility of a king side pawn
storm so I think already White is in a
little bit of trouble here
after h3 it's pretty clear that white
can't play Bishop takes Age 3
because Bishop takes d2 Queen takes e 2
and rook takes h3 and we get our piece
back so
we're gonna be forced what happened here
oh that's actually what happened
interesting so white decides to give
back the piece I guess in order to
establish some lights where resistance
here rook takes f7 okay so this was the
big idea give back the piece but maybe
tried to expose the black king as well
so now after king takes f7 we go queen
f1 and we see this Queen it's gonna get
back the rook and we said that Bishop on
e5 was nice but this knight on d5
doesn't look too shabby either
so black throws in this in-between move
rook g3 and I think this might have been
what white missed because now after you
play King f2 King takes f7 we don't have
that check and Queen takes work anymore
Queen h5 King g7 and rook h1 yeah I
don't know I maybe there was a mistake
in calculation for white maybe he
thought that after rook h1 he had some
devastating attack with Queen h7 but it
looks like everything's protected here
and after Queen h8 white doesn't have
any checks and he's forced to trade
pieces or retreat usually not a good
choice to have to make so now after 97
takes takes and rook f8 I mean this
position is just hopeless right and
black is up a rook and white soon reason
I it so now after g4 wait every time I
thought this was an interesting game too
to start the day off because it's
representative of the essence of this
tournament I think everybody's going
all-out everybody wants that $5,000 of
prize money and they are not afraid to
get their hands dirty it's it's crazy
there's been some crazy things we've
seen so far today and it that was a big
victory for mo police L at ninety the
highest-rated Internet
master in Morocco so it is just after
1800 hours in the Ivory Coast or on the
Ivory Coast I got to check the grammar
on that so we are underway
for round number three and you can join
us at chess 24 calm and see the games
and the famous thermometer of the
evaluation so please join us at chess 24
calm so let's get underway here with our
top seed yep so we have oh well first
let's take a look at the pairings so
these are the games you will be seen in
round number three okay so our what game
would you like to talk about first
Robert well what do you say we start
with the Arthur kion day I mean Bassam
as black against Arthur K on day yep
yeah that sounds great yeah take a look
at that our top seed you know if we if
it's basically who do you pick to win
this event I mean or the field you know
that's got to be the poll right I mean
just telling it like it is this guy is
the number one player in all of Africa
of course the reigning African champion
as well officially Bassam Amin
so let's take a look at that game Robert
all right okay so there we go so we have
round number three Amin playing is black
and going for the nimzo-indian so again
an aggressive opening against which
white counters with III now I think this
is one of the most aggressive setups to
play it as white as well against an M so
Indian usually what white is aiming for
is a position with an isolated Queen
pond which can usually give you some
great attacking prospects for example
after removal a castle casts
see takes the IDI DC bishop see now
there have been countless games played
in this position and some people believe
the isolated Queen pawn is a weakness
others believe it to be a strength it
really depends on the case but I think
if you're gonna come across a strong
isolated queen pawn it's going to be in
these kinds of positions so I I do think
White has great attacking potential here
but in this game white shows a different
approach
you went for Knight G - E - and the idea
of Knight GTE - is to avoid a doubling
of the pawns on c3 because after a while
black got tired of getting attacked with
the isolated queen pawn so there have
been some lines
well actually it's called the Huebner
variation where after I believe knight
c6 Bishop d3 castles or actually even
Bishop takes c3 right away black doesn't
open up the position but rather sets up
a blockade along dark squares and when
the position becomes blocked it's a lot
harder to attack so in order to avoid
these kinds of positions white came up
with the move Knight GE - obviously the
idea is that if you ever go Bishop takes
c3 I go Knight takes c3 and my pawns are
immaculately how much is the bishop
worth been well officially three points
officially three points I don't see I
think the knight is worth three points
but I like to assign it a little bit
more value to the bishop yeah I go like
three and a half maybe four if I'm
feeling crazy so I need to have a very
good reason for trading my bishop for a
knight and usually doubling pawns is
that reason that I'm looking for so
that's why the nimzo-indian is so
interesting
so this basically takes the sting out of
the nihms own black played b6 and the
idea is that if white goes a3 which is
what happened in this game you're not
forced to play Bishop takes c3
because now you can go Bishop a5 and
your pawn on c5 not only puts pressure
on d4 but it prevents white from
continuing to chase your Bishop so white
goes rook b1 renewing the idea of b4 and
now Queen e7 this is really the first
move that stands out to me because this
has been played many many times by many
strong players and black usually opts
for the move Knight to a6 a very
theoretical move and actually roost on
Kasim Donna warmer feed a world champion
recently published a bunch of analysis
in a DVD about 96 so DVDs never do they
still make those I guess they call it a
DVD but you could just you know download
it on the internet but I guess you get
the physical DVD if you want it it's
good to know yeah you could get it on
VHS two people know what that is anymore
so at a great meeting yeah so Queenie 7
maybe not as popular as 96 but notice
it's the same idea
this game is revolving around the fight
for the V for square so after Bishop d2
black castles and this is as far as the
game has gone right or do I need to
refresh double-clicking it no clean oh
oh there we go your moves whoa
let's go back a little bit so after
Queenie 7 Bishop d2 castles d5 so when
you look at this position Ben what do
you what do you see I mean what are some
potential problems that white could have
here white has prevented black from
doubling the pawns but in exchange black
has achieved something this took a lot
of time to do right preventing Bishop
takes c3 I mean we spent moves on 92 and
Bishop d2 black is more developed yeah
yeah exactly so black has a big lead in
development this is not something you're
gonna hear too often right usually white
gets the first move you guess
quickly but here white spent a lot of
moves on addressing issues on the Queen
side and the Kings side has been
somewhat neglected so white played d5
which doesn't really address the problem
of the bishop on f1 now we could try to
go something like g3 followed by a
bishop g2 and castles and I think that's
what White has in mind but he's hoping
maybe that with d5 after he takes d5
there's a tactic trapping this Bishop on
a5 again if white can make before work
the stakes are going to be pretty high
for black because he's kind of lose a
bishop so the idea is that after C takes
before a takes before Bishop takes
before rook takes before sacrificing the
exchange Queen takes before Knight takes
d5 now this position looks pretty
interesting because we gave up an
exchange but now our dark square bishop
that seemed like it wasn't doing much on
d2 it's going to get activated along the
a3 f8 diagonal so for example if we
simply retreated our Queen to the square
d6 Bishop b4 looks pretty annoying you
were yeah nasty skewer and the thing is
that the Queen doesn't look too
comfortable here where is our Queen
gonna go
we can't go to c6 because of 97 York the
skewer morphs into a fork and if our
Queen has to go really far away then
we're gonna get our King side pawn
structure completely destroyed and then
white is gonna get his exchange back
anyway so this looks like a very
interesting idea that white has played a
very interesting sacrifice you could
even call it pseudo sacrifice because we
don't
looks like we're gonna get our exchange
back maybe black has to try something
that could try something like queen bee
- but I'm not sure that's gonna change
much if we just go
Bishop c3 you might have to play queen
a3 and run into this fork as well so at
the moment the game point I think the
game stops at 95 and it's black smooth
the rest is our analysis so we'll see
how that game progresses should we move
on to the different absolutely let's
check it out we have five different
games going and remember this is a rapid
time control so game in 25 with a 10
second delay who knows what it'll look
like at the end of the round
yeah and from what I've seen so far all
the positions looked complicated so it's
a wide open round for everybody all
right so we're gonna be taking a look at
five record Omaha row right now the
number two junior in all of Africa he
represents Madagascar but he lives in
Paris France there's a there's three
players in this tournament who actually
live outside of the nation that they're
representing so he is one of them taking
on David Silva of Luanda Angola the
triple African junior champion so two
juniors going at it right here in round
number three so we might be witnessing
the future African chess here right why
not
all right so let's see how this game
with so d4 Knight f6 Knight c3 already
white playing some line games here
because we start off with d4 and you're
expecting c4 but now white is saying all
of a sudden we might transpose into an
e4 opening and this could be kind of
unpleasant for black especially if you
don't play the perk as black finding
yourself playing a perk when you're not
expecting it it's not the way you want
to start your day so
against Knight c3 Black has to do
something in the center the other option
to prevent efore would be d5 but c5 is
perfectly fine as well and after d5 d6
d4 g6 we're still gonna get a perk like
position Bishop b5 Bishop d7 and a for
White's idea is to make it hard for
black to develop his Queen side saying
okay if you want to develop your Queen
site and you want to make the d7 square
available for your knight
you're gonna have to take on b5 but then
you're just gonna open up the a file for
me and activate my route for free so
also if you chase me away I'm not gonna
take on d7 and help you speed up your
development I'm just gonna drop back and
now it's not going to be easy for you to
untangle this Knight and Bishop
situation you might even end up having
to play something like Bishop c8 in
order to play 97 so blacks said I'll
deal with that later
let me just get my Kings side
development finished Bishop g7 Knight of
three castles h3 h3 is a very important
move because if white is aspiring to get
an advantage here he's going to have to
make it hard for black to achieve this
Queen side development that he's so
desperately wants and the problem if we
play a normal move like castle notice
again how I like to delay castling I
think castling is a passive defensive
move so if there are more useful things
we can do we can keep canceling in our
back pocket and here it would allow
Bishop g4 and this would pretty much
solve blacks Queen side problems because
now we have a place for the bishop and
we've made room for the night we can
even choose to put the F night on d7 and
the other night coming to a6 and c7 and
then we can try to do some Queen side
expansion with
six and be fine look at all those arrows
isn't that confusing I did that
perfectly I can follow that yeah yeah
this is the night hopping around there
so h3 aims to take the g4 square away
from for black Queen a5 Bishop d2 a6 and
Bishop takes d7 so this is a move that
looks a little bit odd to me my first my
gut reaction here would be to retreat
this Bishop maybe to d3 or e2 but since
I've played h3 I don't have to be afraid
of the pin I can just go to d3 and again
I'm just guided by this very simple idea
let's make development hard for our
opponent in the game white when Bishop
takes d7 Knight takes d7 and I mean how
bad can this be for black right we got
all our pieces out we have a decent pawn
structure we didn't have to give up the
bishop pair like when we go Bishop g4
Bishop takes f3 I think blacks position
looks pretty decent
the only thing blacks gonna have to be
careful with is the e5 pawn break so if
y can prepare this for example with
moves like rook e1 Bishop f4 and E 5
maybe we can even include the move
Bishop h2 to tuck this Bishop away make
sure it doesn't get traded off but if we
get you 5 in black might have some
problems so this is the only thing that
black should be concerned about rook b8
rook e1 and I think white is on to this
idea try to push you 598 okay I like
this move again fighting for control
over a 5 look a3 Brooks yes over K 3 we
are looking move right just putting your
rook on the a3 square but it reminds me
of a kind of move Karpov would make we
see that aside from controlling e5 black
might be toying with the idea of playing
b5 and if black goes b5 will go a takes
b-58 takes B 5 and the a file will
become open so white is getting ready to
fight for the
open file in case that opens up of
course I mean is it a risk here though
because it's gen shahad II would call it
that's a rover they broke up and over
but it looks like it's a it's kind of
boxed in there I mean are you are you
certain it'll work I mean if he doesn't
work it looks like you just got your
book in a really horrible spot right
well I actually like rook a3 a lot
because if we ask ourselves is the rook
on a3 worse off than it was on a1 could
we really you know honestly say that it
is I mean what was it doing on a 1 on a
3 not only are we preparing to fight for
the a file but who knows we might even
get to play rugby 3 and put a little bit
of pressure on this pawn on b7 as well
so I think Brooke a3 is this type of
multi-purpose move and that's the
trademark for good moving move it
doesn't just focus on one thing but you
can actually swing over like you said
the rover can actually swing over to the
B file and it frees up our bishop to so
we don't have to be worried about Bishop
takes c3 doubling our pawns rook c8 so
black realized b5 might have been a
little bit too optimistic Bishop f4 and
E 5 is in the works
c4 and this is where we're at so the
position looks I think fairly balanced
but I think White has a slight pull here
just because White's position is much
easier to play I mean we know that E 5
could come at any moment we don't want
to rush it because I think if white
plays d5 here it will lead to a lot of
peace traits that are probably going to
favor black right if we just trade
everything on e5
it's gonna make life easier for the side
with less space that's just a general
principle that when you have less space
you want to trade some pieces so here we
could defend East 7 with moves like King
f8 or maybe your rook c7 preparing
Knight d6 and black has a pretty good
grip on the position I mean once this
Knight gets to d6 let's not forget d6
there's a pseudo outpost an outpost is
simply a square that we control with at
least one of our pawns and our opponent
can't control with any of his pawns
now I said pseudo because there is the
potential that this pawn of the c2 could
eventually get to c5 but that's not
gonna happen anytime soon right so that
night is gonna feel pretty comfortable
on d6 so since E 5 isn't threatening
right away it makes me feel somewhat
optimistic about blacks chances but of
course White has many other moves that
he can try to play I mean one move that
comes to - a5 trying to create a clamp
on the Queen side maybe follow up with
Queen e3 maybe rook a4 and start putting
some pressure on c4 as well I would
rather play white but there's a lot of
play left in this position should we
move on yeah sure you know the players
have just under 20 minutes left it looks
like on average all right we have next
oh the Nigerian player
Oladipo adieu he'll he is the actually
the first international master from all
of West Africa the entire region really
yeah he's taking on the maybe the most
one of the most well known players in
this event the South African Kenny
Solomon who's actually the only Grand
Master in that country
Kenny Solomon resides right now in Italy
so coming back to Africa to try to show
what he's worth in this event so let's
take a look at what has gone down so far
all right let's do that so e for
five Knight f3 knight c6 we get a Rui
Lopez you don't see the reuleaux PES
that often well nevermind I was just
gonna say everybody plays d3 can you
play d3 I haven't seen a classical rule
opus and years probably
I guess the marshal gambit is just too
strong so d6 and I like this approach by
black one of the main weapons that white
has at his disposal in this d3 line is
if black over expands on the Queen site
too soon for example after Bishop b3
Bishop e7 let's say castles castles
white is gonna play a quick a four and
try to get you to advance your pawns as
much as possible on the Queen side and
then maybe was it move like a5 start
taking advantage of some of these weak
squares maybe it was moves like 92
Knight c4 and get some active piece play
on the Queen side so Grandmaster Kenny
Solomon very aware of this is delaying
this move b5 so as not to give white a
target on the Queen side castles g6 or
p1 Bishop g7 C three castles 92 and b5
so maybe now it's a little bit different
because White has already played c3 and
92 so after the move Bishop b3 black
might be ready to expand on the Queen
side as opposed to before where White
was jabbing at his pawns so quickly that
black just had to advance his pawn
forward here after Bishop c2 c5 well why
why wouldn't the bishop just go to c2
straight away if they've the night come
to a5 doesn't that just lose a tempo
well it does but it lowers the Black
Knight to the rim and generally you know
we hear that the knight on the rim is
been as a Port Graham or Grimm yeah or
other wrote words that Ryan yeah poor
slim this tournament - yeah slim is
playing but the idea
is to lure the Knight to a5 and then go
Bishop c2 hoping that this night is
going to be eventually misplaced also if
black the size say hey I'll just leave
my knight in the center the bishop is
more active on b3 than it is on c2
because it puts pressure on the f7
square and on this diagonal in
particular whenever we see black Kincaid
oh we can Kings side we should think
that eventually his idea is going to be
to play something like f5 and attack us
so this is going to make that a little
bit harder so black played 95 anyway
Bishop C 2 and C 5 and this is actually
starting to resemble a classical really
Lopez chigorin variation the difference
is that black has Castle kingside so
that might give him some additional
maybe King side attacking possibilities
9 f1 rook b8 so notice what I was saying
before if white plays a 4 we're by no
means forced to weaken our King side
with a move like V 4 we can probably
just go something like Bishop d7 and
then play Queen c7 complete our
development connect the rooks and then
go about preparing this f5 move so
in the game who's in the game white play
Knight f1 rook b8 Bishop g5 h6 and what
do you think of this Bishop g5 group we
said that black is trying to play for f5
anyway so you would think that h6 is
gonna be a useful move for black because
it's gonna control the g5 square maybe
it's gonna allow me to go King h7 move
the knight go at five not only that it
seems that after h6 white is intending
to give up the bishop for a knight and
we already said you don't do that we
agree right I agree there's eggs worth
more than the night okay good yes so why
don't we give up a bishop for a knight
we need to get something in return
usually that means like in the
nimzo-indian damaging our opponent's
pawn structure in this case we don't
really damage black's pawn structure
because it's already kind of damaged we
see that there's a weak Square on d5 so
the idea of Bishop g5 is to eliminate
the defender of the d5 square well in
this case white played Bishop d2 but the
normal idea when white goes Bishop g5 is
to take and then follow up with Knight
e3 and used the d5 square as a pivot
point for our pieces for example if
black plays Bishop d6 trying to take d5
under control this would be a bad change
in the pawn structure for white because
now white would get doubled pawns and it
would become much much easier for black
to play f5
I mean we could simply go Queen d8 f5
and get our King side rolling so white
wants to occupy the d5 square but not in
a way that it's going to allow black to
change the pawn structure so what we
could do is start off with a move like
b4 and if takes takes knight c6 you can
go a3
and prepare the move Bishop b3 which is
going to increase our control over d5 so
I'm not saying this is particularly good
for white in this case blacks position
looks quite reasonable but this is a
standard approach whenever we see the d5
square as a potential weakness so let's
see what happened in the game because
after Bishop g5 h6 white double back
played Bishop d2 why do you do that
that's a good question
I'm thinking that white is happy to have
provoked h6 thinking that this could be
a potential weakness later but also
preparing some play on the Queen side
based on moves like B 4 and a 4 now when
I first learned the game of chess I was
taught that we develop our pieces
towards the center and that the center
is very important but later I realized
that this is maybe not completely
accurate we definitely want our Knights
close to the center for example the
Knights on f3 and III would be very good
because Knights or short-range pieces
they can't move as fast as bishops the
bishops you want them pointing to the
center of it not necessarily occupying
the center because there are easy
targets and like we said we don't
usually want our bishops to get traded
for Knights so I really like the d2
square for the bishop notice how these
arrows point to both sides of the board
so whenever your bishop is operating on
both flanks you can be sure that your
bishops doing okay in fact it would be
very interesting for white to play
something like Queen c1 and Bishop d1
and then both bishops would be pointing
to both flanks I am a fan of this Bishop
arrangement d2 and d1 I think they're
kind of tucked away so they're safe but
at any moment they could spring into
action so I think that's maybe the
reason behind Bishop
- so let's see what happened after
Knight c6 Bishop b3 985 Bishop c200 move
repetition and look at this black
refuses to repeat moves Bishop e6 9390
c6 Bishop b3 Queen d7 black completed
development it looks like he has decent
control over d5 in fact I think one of
blacks main ideas in this position is to
play the move d5 and start gaining space
in the center I mean if he can go d5 d4
black is gonna find himself sitting
pretty because White's position looks a
little bit cramped it's not so often
that you get to see black with the space
advantage so white plays Knight f1
hoping that this will deter black from
playing define because now the rook is
putting in direct pressure on e5 along
with the knight as we'll see black plays
d5 anyway and white goes Knight g3
because after a takes d5 Knight takes d5
and we see that this pawn is well
protected by the bishop and the knight
not only that the movie takes d5 has
exposed a target for black this backward
pawn on d3 so black can actually prepare
a move like rook d8 and then the Knights
going to retreat from d5 maybe to c7 and
we're gonna have some problems defending
d3 so white decides to keep the center
essential tension so to not make any
rash decisions and after 93 c4 so I
think it's fair to say that black has
gone on the offensive already II d5
Queen D v DC form
BC for Bishop a4 and this is where we're
at I think that a black has played very
ambitiously but it's not entirely clear
to me what's happening here because
maybe black thought he could take this
pawn on b2 but after Bishop takes c6
queen takes c6 Knight takes e5 this
position looks pretty decent for black
he has the bishop pair he has an active
rook on b2 I think overall more active
pieces but at least white is not feeling
so cramped anymore never the last night
I don't think this is a good position
for white maybe white can I mean maybe
black and just move the Queen to
somewhere like b7 or b5 and I think he
just has the bishop pair and more active
pieces so this game is looking good for
black I think it's looking good for
Solomon but he is at about half the time
that I do has and in a rapid game with
just a 10 seconds that's a good point I
didn't notice that yeah you know things
can happen but yeah right now I agree
with you totally these quicker time
controls you got to think of the clock
as an extra piece you know you get in
terrible time pressure it's like you're
down a piece so and the worth of it
always changes that's true very dynamic
might be a queen yeah especially because
we don't have increment in this
tournament
no increment yeah it's also nice this is
based after the grand chest or rapid and
blitz events and actually just earlier
this year last month we saw the events
in Leuven Belgium and Paris France the
first legs of the grand chest or later
on actually just in a couple of weeks
we're gonna have the st. Louis rapid
embolus this is gonna be the same format
everybody you know so of course you can
check that on grand chest or that org
but right now it's all about chest 24
calm and and this rapid and blitz event
from the Ivory Coast so while we're
still making our way down the line I
think we have
two more games to glance at before we
start digging in mm-hmm vocalist Ella
Adnani and versus Arthur say gwaan e1 ye
you must excuse my pronunciation I
haven't been able to hear from the
players themselves on how to pronounce
their name so hopefully a lot of them
are phonetic and I might be making a
fool of myself
but we'll get them right eventually so
let's take a look at this game I think
we can strike a deal all pronounce the
first names and you do the last things
like I'll do Arthur and you can do his
last name alright let's do it alright so
let's see what happened here efore b-59
f3 knight c6 it should be fine so we
have another Lopez and now the co-ceo
variation some people actually call this
the Aronian variation really yeah and
Aronian has been playing this a lot and
I think some of his most famous games in
this line were played in the st. Louis
tournaments whether Sinquefield Cup or
rapid and blitz events it's not
surprising yeah it's I think an accurate
reflection of the current paradigm in
chess theory which is not necessarily to
play main lines but rather to choose
practical lines so if you study the
Marshall gambit for example theory
starts on move like fifteen or twenty so
there are so many things that can happen
beforehand so you could be starting the
Marshall gambit for hours and hours and
you would maybe get like one or two
games a year but if you study night g7
you're just cutting through all that
theoretical red tape you know to get to
the line that you study so this is this
is a very practical move there is an
incredible value sort of an uncapped
resource how useful it is to actually
get the position that you study as
opposed to it being like an excellent
position it's much better to just have
like an equal game that you understand
really well and an advantage
it's a total mess so that's my
impression is on the current state of
opening theory so white goes c3 g6 d4
takes takes b5 Bishop b3 Bishop g7
notice again we see this Bishop
retreating to b3 as opposed to going to
see two in one move
we are not troubled by the fact that
black can gain this free tempo
quote-unquote because after Bishop c2
this night on a5 might not be doing so
well they don't a fine so black goes
Bishop g7 d5 and notice how white
actually provokes 985 after d5 95 Bishop
C to d6 now we start seeing some of the
potential problems with this night on a5
it's not quite dominated yet but it
doesn't have an easy way to retreat back
to safety so a for Bishop d7 94
b4b three castles and rook a - does this
seem like a weird position to you well
yeah any-any usually positions with we
work on a two is a weird position yeah
this looks pretty weird to me - it seems
like weight is making some unnatural
moves I mean he hasn't developed his
queen side yet hasn't castled
and he's making moves like rookie - well
obviously you know this diagonal should
be a concern so getting the rook out of
a 1-1 pins the knight on d4 but I think
it also highlights a problem that black
might have in this position and that is
these two knights not just the nine on
85 but also the 997 look misplaced and
when you have misplaced pieces it's hard
to take advantage of your opponent's
lack of development so white can afford
himself to make this work a to move
because this knight on e7 is blocking
the e-file so we can't really take
advantage of the King on e1 and this
knight on e5 seems to be dominated by
the white pawns you can't go to c4 can't
go to c6 I mean it can go to b7 it's
probably gonna have to go to b7 and try
to get to c5 at some point that would be
a huge improvement for black so maybe
this is blacks idea there we go
97 castles h6 Bishop b2 and Knight see
fine
so this is where we're at in the game I
think black has radically improved his
position in the last couple of moves
because this Knight was dominated on a5
but now as c5 it's again on a pseudo
outpost so technically not an outpost
because white does have the potential to
play b4 at some point but again this is
not going to happen any time soon the
only other issue for black to solve here
is this knight on e7 and I think he
intends to do this by either playing
f-five taking on e4 and going Knight f5
but this might also weaken the e6 square
the other way would be me this is it
right yeah the other way would be to go
g5 and bring the knight to g6 so this
would be less of a commitment in terms
of weakening your pawn structure it's
it's strange right
go g5 and say that doesn't weaken your
pawn structure as much but really you
have much better control over f5 than
you would over a six so if I was white I
might consider a move like I mean the
most natural move would be Knight d2 and
here I don't know if to go f5 or to go
g5 I mean if c six is not a problem that
f5 should be fine but otherwise maybe
the move g5 could be interesting as well
and maybe after Knight c4 we could try
Knight g6 and yeah I don't know maybe f5
is not looking so hot here maybe white
can also try to use this outpost this is
a full-fledged outpost on c6 line at
night there yeah maybe
g5 it's not as good as I thought maybe
we just have to go at five and just make
it a messy game I don't think so
I think the position at the moment is at
night c5 the rest I kind of made those
moves okay yeah let's see we have so
we're down to our final game final game
I don't gain I insist sit here now
haven't looked at Mohamed had Boucher
and slingback oh yeah that's right did
we know we didn't they were just got an
order from top down I I did it
completely random oh just so make it
hard fierce yeah exactly
I enjoy a challenge I found it look at
that yeah all right well Mohammad Abdu
Shea is one of three grandmasters from
Algeria he resides
in his home country in Algiers and then
slim Bell hoja who I've been told we may
not actually get to talk to him
throughout the duration because he is
not doesn't have English as a first
language does doesn't speak it too well
but who knows it might be able to
he's Africa's first grandmaster and the
only Grandmaster currently from Tunisia
and he lives in Paris so let's take a
look at what we've had so far all right
so we have other e45 it seems to be like
the the current trend against efore just
the man on man coverage b-45 we have a
Philidor defense he takes Queen takes d4
so the main move here is Knight takes d4
and I think what black usually goes for
is something like this and the reason I
want to go into this lines because one
of my favorite openings is black and I
want to share one of these general
principles I'm so fond of general
principles they make life so much easier
I don't have to think I just do stuff
that looks right it usually is so most
mistakes come when you have to start
thinking you're my coach used to tell me
you got to think with your fingers so
and chest that would be the equivalent
of like muscle muscle memory in sports
okay so after castles for example rook
e8 rook e1 bishop f8 this is how I like
to deal with bishops I think the opening
is the worst part of the game for the
bishop because it gets in the way of
everything so in the opening what I try
to do is I try to get the bishops out so
they can bring my rooks to the center
and once my rooks are centralized I love
putting the bishop back on its initial
square because now it doesn't interfere
with the rook it's not vulnerable to
attack so it's tucked away nice and safe
on f8 and when the moments right it'll
spring into action
maybe with a move like a timely ed5 and
then this bishops going to come out to
see fine I can say it was certainly I've
never done that that [ __ ] is
just the concept is bizarre to me but it
makes sense that you explained it that
way yeah and I think that you see this
type of concept in a lot of games but
not a lot of people articulated in that
way so trying to articulate complicated
maneuvers in simple terms is how I go
about chess and I recently played a game
where I took this strategy that I just
applied on the kingside and applied it
on the queenside as well let me just
show you really quick what I would do
and I would go something like 97 sure
about 495 h3 Bishop d7 and guess what
I'm gonna do after Bishop d7 am I
excited about putting a bishop on d7 did
I just complete development my bishops
amazing now we're thinking for c8 not
quite because rook c8 would take the
square away from the bishop so what I
want to do is after Queen d2 I want to
go Queen c7 after rook do you want I
want to go rook b8 and if you whatever
you do then I'm gonna go Bishop c8 and
look at this okay all right
are you feeling me now uh I guess I
guess so yeah don't the look rooks look
nice yeah they're just pointing at the
center they are and look at it it's
getting some air support from the
bishops - and the Knights are
centralized so we keep our Knights
physically in the center but we keep sir
keep our bishops away from the center
but pointing at it so that they don't
get attacked
can I go off track here a little bit a
little bit yeah just a little bit I am
looking at the notation it's pretty
obscene how far off track you went but
no we're all right back to the game all
right
I digress anyway Queen takes d4 isn't
another approach yeah after all that
bishops belong in the back rank kinda
that's that's the new date principle
yeah yeah I I'm trying to
you know make it stick so queen d1 a six
this should a four so notice we have a
certain trend regarding the appreciation
of the pawn structure right black
doesn't want to allow white to double
his pawns on c6 so we're playing 97 in
the hopes that white will do something
ridiculous like let's say Knight c3 and
after a6 always gonna have no choice but
to give up the bishop pair and again
when we give up the bishop we usually
want to at least damage or opponent's
pawn structure not something we would be
achieving here because this Knight d7
maneuver allows black to keep healthy
pawn structure so white goes Queen d1
and after a six they should pay for
Knight g6 castles Bishop e7 ninth c3 all
pretty normal development h3 Bishop e6
or p1 Queen d7
Knight d5 so I think white is getting a
pretty comfortable position without
doing much here
I mean we put this night as nimzowitsch
would call it the sentinel on d5 taking
advantage of the fact that Bishop takes
d5 is just gonna drop at peace after
edie and what is black gonna do or is he
gonna put his bishops there's a maneuver
here that you can try and that is to go
over 88 this is what happened in the
game and the idea is that you're gonna
tuck the bishop away on d8 now you could
have saved yourself a lot of trouble by
using my approach and coming rook F EA
and Bishop FA and rook 88 and Bishop CA
but this is gonna be a similar idea
because after c4 black goes Bishop d8
and again the bishop is away from the
center but remember we were talking
about a couple of games ago when I said
I liked my bishops on d2 and d1 yeah
because they point to both sides of the
board well I think that black is trying
to do something similar because this
Bishop on d8 has the potential to strike
on both sides and okay the bishops not
on d7 but it's on e6 which is a pretty
decent square because it also controls
both sides of the board so black has a
solid position he is a little bit
cramped but it shouldn't be too bad and
now b5 okay so now that black completed
his development and all his pieces are
more or less defended he goes for these
complications and the idea is if you go
C takes b5
I'm gonna go Knight takes d4 and after
Queen tasty 4 I get my pawn back and I
start pushing your pieces back as well
notice for example after Bishop b3 I can
start kicking your night out and look at
this Bishop it didn't look so hot a
couple moons ago but all of a sudden we
get that payoff there it is yeah so as
to Coast very interesting
played by black white took on c6 and
after Queen takes pawn takes on tanks
and I'm actually starting to like blacks
position because white is still
underdeveloped and his bishops this
might sound strange seem to be doing
worse than blacks bishops if anything
this Bishop could actually drop back to
d7 because it's in the way of the rook
and from d7 it's gonna do an even better
job and it's doing from p6 so after
Bishop b3 Queen d7 Bishop III and c6 so
this Bishop on da is playing a key role
Knight c3 I'm guessing Knight b6 would
be a terrible move because I can just
trap your knight
you don't want to do that right so nice
c3 and Bishop a5 look at this that's how
you use your bishops Queen c2 and what
are my feelings on Bishop takes c3 I'm
being told that there is a result
actually let's take a look yes indeed
Kenney Solomon has defeated all addabbo
adieu let's take a look at what happened
in that game yeah so where did we leave
off in this game oh that's right this
crazy kind of rule opus game where we
were talking about the position after
Bishop a4 so black ended up winning this
position I was kind of optimistic about
blacks chances here and we had only
looked at rook takes b2 in the game
black went 497 I guess he wants to take
on b2 but he doesn't want to lose the e5
pawn so 97 keeps this pawn very
well-protected white goes
b4 trying to shake this pressure and
loose on the Queen side and now f5 I've
been talking a lot about bishops today
there's nothing wrong with that so I
think I should talk a little bit about
Knights now did you know that Knights
usually feel pretty uncomfortable if
they're sitting in front of their pawns
well now that you mention it it makes
sense
Knights like to be in back of their paws
the pawn is sort of like a bodyguard for
the night so in order to get to the
night you got to get through me the pawn
says so when you put the Knights in
front of the pawn you alter the natural
order of things and the Knights can
become quite vulnerable all right
they're very least dominated by your
opponent's pawns and this is what we're
seeing in this game these pawns on e5 +
f5 look very threatening to these
Knights particularly this epon because
black is threatening to go F or
harassing the white knight and I don't
see a good Square for this night so
white goes Queen c2 now I said e for
because f4 looks like a very ugly move
giving white a nice outpost on e4 this
is not how we dominate Knights we don't
give them outposts but e for I'm
wondering what was wrong with efore here
this looks like an interesting move
because you're going after these Knights
right away maybe I don't know as Bishop
takes c6 the problem Queen takes and 94
but this looks like a great kind of ugly
pawn structure for white although maybe
our dark squares become weak I'm not
buying it I think we could probably just
go King h7 blacks position looks very
good here - let's see what black had in
mind
all right Queen d6 in one go
now root be one reason c7 to me it's
kind of a red flag when you start
decentralizing your pieces I take that
as a sign that maybe something it's not
going rightly and you black missed
something of course his position is so
good that he can afford to play some
passive moves but usually you always
want to be pushing forward right not
dropping back so a three Bishop f7 Queen
c1 King age seven so I guess black is
just taking his time he knows he has
more space and when you have more space
usually he's you have more time
h4 and there we go efore so this is the
move I was expecting a few moves ago now
okay Bishop f4 Queen c8 oh my goodness
what is this I guess if white I mean if
black wanted to prepare even more you
could have thrown in and moved like rook
b8 at some point so that Bishop matte
form wouldn't win in exchange but made
me black had something else in mind here
oh no he just sacked the exchange just
like that Knight d4 Knight be fine oh I
see so the idea is to use this super
outpost on d3 for the night I'm guessing
these types of speculative sacrifices I
mean the blacks position looks good are
even more powerful when you're dealing
with a rapid time control Robert sorry
to interrupt we have yet another result
as the players are getting into time
trouble we we know that reco tomorrow
the International Master has defeated
David Silva that is what we anticipated
it could have happened and so that has
happened right now Kenny Solomon stands
at three out of six possible points so
he's even on the day and reco tomorrow
is a very impressive five out of six the
live leader so excellent alright so what
do you say we see how Solomon
ended up bringing a whole point home in
this game after 93 takes takes he seems
to have gotten a lot of compensation for
this exchange because we have this
protective past pollen on d3 and these
tremendous bishops again it's all about
the bishops Queen d2 97 h5 95 so things
got a little bit crazy on the King sight
but it looks like the bishops are able
to take care of business and defend as
well as attack so 94 Knight takes e4
maybe a move made out of desperation
because it looks like Bishop g5 is
coming and maybe the black Queen can try
to break in through da and h4 and h2 so
white gives up a piece and wow you know
this is completely hopeless position
three minor pieces for a rook and we
still have this protected passed pawn on
d3 yeah this game is pretty much over
not too many surprises here okay very
nice game by Solomon who else did you
say that finished
besides Solomon Rick Omaha Rho has
defeated David Silva and then Andrew K
on date has drawn with Bassam Amin and
that game actually looked like White was
winning for a little bit and then it
petered out into a draw
where Amin was able to force it free
fold
yeah let's go back to the Amin game
because we had left it off after the
move Knight takes d5 so kion they
definitely not intimidated by his high
profile opponent and going all out in
the opening and look at this was it's
just sacrificing the Queen oh we didn't
consider this move Knight takes d5
Bishop takes Queen Knight takes what is
the piece count here so we have a rook
and a knight and how many pawns for the
Queen one pawn rook night and pawn for
the Queen interesting I've never seen
this position before Knight c3 Bishop d7
somehow I just think like white is up at
clean I don't really see the big problem
in White's position Bishop e2 Bishop c6
castles 85 all right so maybe black is
going to create some Queen side problems
we have this outside passed pawn and we
have some interesting outposts on c5 and
b4 do you know what Knights love more
than apples
outposts yes absolutely so maybe we can
get two nights on two outposts and
wouldn't that be nice
Queen D 496 Queen takes a 4
this makes me unhappy as black because I
wanted to outposts and after you chop
down my b6 pawn I no longer have an
outpost on c5 well maybe if I go d6 but
this deep on really it's job is to
protect the bishop so after a for Queen
D for a 3 ok so just this pawn on a3
might be a problem
rook the 8th there should be three
Knights e7 rook a 196 ween d6 now you've
mentioned that white might have been
winning in this game and White's
position definitely looks quite
intimidating I mean the Queen is
centralized on d6 can't really be kicked
out and I'm thinking that something like
Knight d5 could happen at any moment
because if white is able to shut down
the Queen side then the Queen is just
going to rip through blacks position so
after rook d7 f4 I like this just to
give the King a little bit of breathing
room a to f5 night MA
Queen d2 so white really wants to get
rid of this a to pawn the problem is
that if you ever take this pawn you
might get pinched forever right for
example route k3 if you go Bishop takes
a - I would think that after I move like
rook a7 you're gonna have a very hard
time getting this Bishop out of here or
getting this rook out of here for that
matter so white goes Queen B - and
Knights see - Wow
nice shot so obviously you can't go
Bishop takes Knight because your queen
is hanging and if you go Queen takes
which is what happened in the game I
think over it takes and apparently you
can't go Knight takes a - you know what
would be the problem here I don't know I
would chop down that pawn the first
chance I got but I guess it's not easy
to move now right let's say I I just
make a move what are you gonna do is
work you have you still have a mega pin
there I mean yeah it's crazy because if
you look at the material White has even
improved his material situation because
he has an extra pawn now whereas before
he was down upon but you can't move
right you can't move the knight can you
move the rook for example can I just go
something like rook f1
this is funny I can just like you still
can't move this night was its night
Siwon I don't know I would have been a
little bit worried about just giving up
my a to pawn like that but after rook
takes III I'm guessing this night is
coming into the game and it's still not
easy for black to get for white to get
this night into the game so white went
95 and after Bishop takes pawn takes
rook c3 Queen B 2 and here we had a
repetition of moves I guess this makes
sense I mean if white tries to play for
a win here with a move like Queen to f2
how would you play here Ben well
wait like to play and win check out this
band oh nice yeah yeah so now you take
and I queen and unfortunately you have
no good way of protecting the bank rank
so you have to give up your queen and
now black is just off the piece so I
mean pushing all the way even though he
was you know missing his queen he's got
a lot of compensation yeah I was
definitely going to request that we talk
to Andrew Conde at the end of the round
before that result Moustafa the two more
games going on it looks like with just
oh seconds for oh okay that games a draw
Muhammad Abduh che and slim Bell Ho Chi
I have drawn there's one game left let's
take a look at it just for the sake of
being live it's L at 90 versus say Guan
Yi it says that it's still live I'm not
sure if just the result hasn't
registered yet alive for long yes I
liked with the lost of rook here right
so not this games probably been
resilient there oh no that's that they
put the Kings in Korea yeah it's tough
being an armor sometimes you know you
gotta know which way to put yeah and you
know you tell them once you tell them
twice I still don't get it
absolutely so what I've been trying to
do over here is connect with our friends
on the Ivory Coast mm-hmm via the magic
of Skype and try to get a couple players
on the line here so we're gonna try this
interview who do you think we should get
Kenny Solomon Kenny Psalm would be good
I would also be interested in hearing
what koa felt during his game against a
mean because that was a crazy game I
want to know if that exchange sacrifice
was something he had prepared or if he
just thought of it on the fly
just to pull up that position this d5
followed by b4 move setting up the
exchange sacrifice right rook takes and
now Knight takes d5 really putting all
the pressure on black and in fact black
came up with the solution of sacrificing
the Queen and I think you know it black
barely held on in this game I think he
was if anything on the defensive for
most of the time what does this say to
you so far I mean that we had given a
mean too much credit that anything can
happen in a rapid game because he didn't
just run away today
like everyone might have fought he would
not at all I mean I was very surprised
to see him go for this approach but in a
way it makes sense because when you're
playing a higher rated more experienced
player usually the battleground they
want to take you to is to these quiet
games where they can outmaneuver you I
mean grandmasters are pretty good at
maneuvering for endless periods of time
with seemingly no goal in mind I mean
that's basically my life philosophy so
your best shot is to go for the knockout
so in that in that regard
White's opening choice and then his
exchange sacrifice make a lot of sense
because it muddied the waters but it
also looked incredibly dangerous so I
think this is the way to really try to
do some damage to a mean in this
tournament so I understand that we are
going to be talking to Kenny Solomon
first so let me attempt to get this is
this is all alive right here folks so
bear with us the connection was quite
good last night let's see if we can do
it today it's just
oh dear Skype is very cheerful alright
let's see what we have here we have Ken
there he is there's Kenny hey let me I'm
gonna unmute the speaker's here I think
it works yes it does hello can you hear
us
yeah wonderful congratulations mr.
Solomon on your victory today Ben Simon
and Robert Lang gaskey here in the
studio talking with South Africa's only
Grandmaster Kenny Solomon Kenny at
before we get to the game I hope what
does this tournament mean to you this is
something we've never done before and
we're proud to present it what does this
tournament mean to you oh I think it's
it's the first of us format Africa and
it's a good experience second delay
10-second delay and three second delay
in the Blitz it's it's it's interesting
and I think it's a unique tournament a
unique tournament for all of us
participating in Africa I'm happy to be
part of it yeah
Robert has a few questions for you can
he take it away to see me uh he can't
see you right now a game that computer
doesn't turn that way that he can hear
you all right Kenny this is a
grandmaster Robert on gaskey big fan
I've been following your games I was
hoping I could ask you a couple
questions about your game so there were
two moments all right let's bring let's
try bringing the board up here there was
two moments that I thought I knew what
you were gonna play and you didn't and
you didn't one was after you played c4d
takes c4 beat
see for Bishop a4 did you think about
rook takes b200c falls and maybe the
last game we played I mean I was playing
black I went c4 yeah he played in D yeah
and I went you I went I mean come takes
d5 yeah yeah and then there's only the B
file opened up and you could have played
rook takes B - I didn't play with big
beetles
no oh well I was worried about Bishop c6
okay
Quincy six my I takes e5 and some
couldn't see one ideas nicely so so if
we move the Queen away Queen c1 maybe an
eight-six is hanging all right and then
later on in the game once you've got a
fantastic position after you played f5
you've played this move Queen b6 and and
you retreated your queen to c7 yeah this
was efore possibility instead of Queen
d6 now I'm soft queen if I swap on
before I was I was worried about you
should f4 and Group B to D one
interesting and I threw my queen getting
stuck in the middle of the board and I
thought okay I shouldn't try to
calculate okay now that makes a lot of
sense I completely nuts that idea of
Bishop f4 so later on in the game you
sacrifice the exchange and you got a
fantastic position a lot of compensation
right actually I must before you know
your music so you saw Bishop f4 when it
was really hard to see it and then after
Queen c1 well fortunately your position
was so good that it it didn't really
change the evaluation with was thorns on
c4 and E for I think I have enough
compensation and I think it was actually
a mistake for white to play Bishop
captures the rook on da
Oh a lot of control on the dark squares
and possibility of my jumping to e5 in
to d3
yeah
I think Blanche's has used space spatial
advantage with with both horns on the
far end
if one c4 I think I should have kept the
bishop on f4 and just just keep keep
some keep the bishops on a4 and F while
they're quite strong maybe just move
Knight yeah I think I think the last few
moves got a bit messy in the time time
time scramble but I managed to activate
my knight on b8 to d7 and eventually got
to do d3 no once you've got to d3 I
think I have enough compensation be
honest all right well congratulations on
a very nice game and good luck and the
rest of the tournament thank you so much
all right thanks all right that's
Grandmaster Kenny Solomon
we'll have another guest in here shortly
so Wow the magic of Skype look I'm
impressed by the little things in life
and that's one of them okay we're like
the Internet is a little thing and I was
like the live video conferencing I mean
what's better right now it's great it's
awesome stuff I just in my first
interview I'm pretty happy about it yeah
it's very good today
thank you even though they couldn't see
you they could hear you and that's
what's important yeah right now we have
our second guests though on the line
Andrew K on day who just took on Bassam
Amin Andrew welcome to the show thanks
for being here and I got to ask am I
saying your last name correctly yes
you're trying well how do you say say it
for us please I'm drew Conde I am day
okay thank you very much we're doing our
best here so what is it what does this
spectacular tournament mean to you
well it's a first of its kind where you
have top guys from Africa or plane and
from their respective countries so for
me it's Shaka Seng the best that Africa
can offer and to me it's it's it's a big
privilege to be participating in this
event so you are the four-time Zambian
national champion today you took on the
top ranked player in all of Africa what
were your thoughts going into this game
so actually I'm the sixteenth I had hit
six times six times pardon me okay so I
recently played bass him in the Africa
and individual championship and like to
get this game again I wasn't in up okay
so going into the game was a little bit
confident I took my chances bringing
that bad looking at the previous game I
played against him all right well so
Robert would like to take you through
the game here and talk about some points
hi Andrew there is a grandmaster
Robertson gaskey I was following your
game along really excited game
I was hoping I could ask you a couple
questions about the game no problem so I
was a little bit surprised by your
opponent's choice of Queen e7 which is
not the main move in that opening that
you answered with a very interesting
exchange sacrifice now was that
something you came up with over the
board or did you prepare that he's a guy
he's one that deviated so it was part of
my home preparation to the chamber she
took on he takes d5 so as you do that
moment I think he deviated and he
blundered in exchange Queen in exchange
okay so it is he forced to give up the
clean in that position it's the best
it's the best continuation in that
position otherwise I have enormous
attack on the Kings side so I think it
was it was a good choice
practical trades from vacuum yeah
because it looks like he does have a
fairly good control over the Queen side
and especially that outside pass pawn
can create some problems because you're
like your lights for dishes isn't isn't
so great and nevertheless your position
was close to winning at some point and
do you feel like you could have improved
your play at some point I think I the
plan I did not properly play my knight
so I needed my knight to go into the
attack so on c3 after Knight c3 I really
did not follow up very well because now
I say moving my Queen giving him tempo
and thereafter he started to slowly
equalize so I think I should have paid
my knight better probably taking it too
F for something to do with g7 okay so
for example if Knight f4 and let's say
he goes Bishop b7 like he played in the
game you would still play Bishop e2 and
Ace and Castle and then you go Queen d4
Knight h5 something like that right yes
okay yeah that seems interesting because
let's say like Bishop c6 castles a5 now
Queen d4 you're saying that aside from
the pressure on b6 you also have some
nasty ideas on the Kings side with
Knight h5 threatening checkmate so
that's a very interesting improvement
okay
and after you played Knight c3 the game
went on it seemed like your opponent was
able to finish his Queen side
development and push that outside passer
was there any other moment in the game
where you felt like you could have
pressed harder maybe show planned 493
was to take the Knight to d6 and so nice
e3 95-96 was what I initially wanted to
do mm-hmm but something made me change I
died I don't I really don't understand
how I hide it I thought I was better
taking the point so
it was just I go in 23 year plan so
1995-96 and with an idea of 95 okay so
you try you trying to aim for the
kingside again because the interesting
thing is if he takes on b5 then after C
takes b5 this knight on b8 is out of the
game right so he has he has to let your
Knight get to d6 okay exactly
so maybe instead of Queen before we have
95 so we have a couple of different ways
that I think would have given white at
least some very real winning chances
there yes okay and then afterwards and
things got a little bit crazy I guess in
in time trouble because it seemed like
you could just easily capture that a
pawn but all of a sudden there were
these back rank tactics and this Knight
and Bishop on c3 and a2 were poorly
coordinated so your opponent found a
nice move repetition there all right
correct
well it wasn't quite a win but I think
it was still a great game
congratulations and good luck in the
rest of the frozen alright thanks for
best all right thank you very much and
that's live Skype from hotel teamö
in the ivory coast and that was
international master Andrew K on day six
time
Zambian national champion and you forget
chi yeol day now you only get that work
on that so we have had a nice opening
day of rapid chess three rounds are in
the books and if we have it I'd like to
take a look at our standings after our
first day of play now remember each game
was worth two points
the blitz games later on in the fourth
and fifth days will be worth only one
point so these if these scores look
inflated it's because they are they're
gonna work with the blitz games later on
so what do you make after this first day
we have a three-way tie for first well
I'm surprised that a mean is not part of
that three-way time right
starters so that just tells us that you
know there might be some very dangerous
players that we might not have
considered before this tournament
started so it's very exciting and
especially because like we said in the
beginning getting a slight lead now
gives you a little bit of a buffer in
case of unexpected turns you could say
in the blitz portion exactly and and
everybody well nine of the players have
made it on the board in some form or
another and in case you're wondering
that fee deck on the upper left is the
Ivorian Chess Federation need to give
them a shout out of course as one of the
hosts of this grand tournament and
anything could happen Robert rabbit and
blitz yeah and that fee dick logo is
actually an elephant was it tusks did
you notice that oh my gosh it is yeah
look at that nice I'm good at these
things I pick up quick you already knew
that didn't know I did it I kind of
looked at it and saw the elephant
graphic designers everywhere are very
proud you know right well thank you very
much so the first day has ended and
we're gearing up for four more days of
play remember tomorrow is another day of
rapid chess and then on Friday we will
have our final day of rapid and then
blitz over the weekend two days of that
so join us tomorrow at 12:45 central
time 1745 UTC we're done yes oh man
getting started sorry yeah the games are
over that went by fast I was having a
good time just looking at these games
and talking enough to wait too long
because remember while our show is only
90 minutes long the rounds begin a
couple hours beforehand all right so
that would be three in the afternoon in
the Ivory Coast is when the games start
tomorrow and we'll be on at 1745 5:45 in
the evening Ivory Coast time 12:45
Central time right here in st. Louis and
we do hope that you join us at chess 24
calm and on youtube so this show was
produced by the world's greatest B team
Tammi Hyde is the technical adviser
making sure the stream doesn't drop
Isaac Krantz is the audio and graphics
man our technical director today has
been Dennis LaRue my name is Ben Simon
hi I'm Robert Wong gaskey that was the
best thing ever and until tomorrow we
say so long from the show-me-state yeah
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you